JOHN.
>> John: PERHAPS HE WILL STAY
AROUND FOR A WHILE YET.
KRISTIN FISHER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR US.
THANKS.
WHILE THE LABOR SECRETARY IS
STAYING FOR NOW, BRITAIN'S
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED STATES
IS OUT.
KIM DEREK RESIGNED TODAY AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ESSENTIALLY
GHOSTED HIM OVER SECRET
CRITICISM THAT BECAME PUBLIC.
REPORTER KITTY LOGAN HAS THE
LATEST FORCE FROM LONDON
TONIGHT.
>> UNDER FIRE FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND PERSONA
NON GRATA IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
KIM DEREK SAID THE CURRENT
SITUATION MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
STAY ON.
ADDING "THE RESPONSIBLE HORSE IS
TO ALLOW THE APPOINTMENT OF A
NEW AMBASSADOR.
ADDRESSING PARLIAMENT TODAY,
PRIME MINISTER THERESA MAY GAVE
THE EMBATTLED AMBASSADOR OR
BACKING.
>> I TOLD HIM THAT IT IS A
MATTER OF GREAT REGRET THAT HE
HAS FELT IT NECESSARY TO LEAVE
HIS POSITION.
SIR KIM HAS GIVEN A LIFETIME OF
SERVICE TO THE UNITED KINGDOM
AND WE OWE HIM AN ENORMOUS DEBT
OF GRATITUDE.
>> BUT THAT GRATITUDE COMES AT
AN EXPENSE.
IN A PARLIAMENTARY COMMITTEE
HEARING EARLIER TODAY, THE HEAD
OF BRITISH DIPLOMATIC SERVICE
SAID THE RISK BETWEEN THE TWO
ALLIES WAS THE WORST IN OVER A
CENTURY.
>> THE LAST TIME THAT I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE DIFFICULTY WITH
UNITED STATES WAS 1856.
WHEN THE INCUMBENT WAS ACCUSED
OF RECRUITING AMERICANS TO FIGHT
ON THE BRITISH SIDE IN THE
CRIMEAN WAR.
>> IN A TWEET YESTERDAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED THE
AMBASSADOR A VERY STUPID GUY AND
ON MONDAY TWEETED THAT HE NO
LONGER WANTED TO DEAL WITH DEREK
AND DISINVITED HIM FROM A STATE
DINNER.
THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS CAME
AFTER A LEAK OF CONFIDENTIAL
BRITISH EMBASSY MEMOS IN WHICH
DEREK DESCRIBES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AS INAPT AND
DYSFUNCTIONAL.
>> I THINK WHOEVER LEAKED HIS
DETAILS HAS REALLY DONE A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO OUR CIVIL
SERVANTS, DO PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN
ADVICE TO MINISTERS.
>> KIM DEREK WILL FORMULA
STEPPED ON ONCE HIS SUCCESSOR IS
APPOINTED.
WHILE THE GOVERNOR MAY NOT HAVE
WANTED THE AMBASSADOR TO RESIGN,
IT WILL SURELY BE HOPING THAT
HIS DEPARTURE BRINGS THE MATTER
TO AN END.
>> STILL MIGHT BE EMBARRASSING
LEAK IS URGENTLY BEING
INVESTIGATED.
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS IT'S HAD
INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
POLICE, ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE NO
FORMAL INQUIRY YET.
IT'S THOUGHT THAT ONLY A FEW
PEOPLE COULD HAVE HAD ACCESS TO
SUCH HIGH-LEVEL CONFIDENTIAL